ja beinahe sechs monate krieg in der
ukraine und wir haben ganz aktuelle
aufnahmen aus der stadt ließ sich ganz
im osten des landes die schoko nuss ist
hier einmal im osten des landes in der
region luhansk wurde anfangen hier haben
wir es anfang juli vom russischen
truppen erobert und ist seitdem an sich
unter russischer kontrolle und relativ
ruhig geworden ist es da ruhig geworden
bis gestern gestern haben uns dann diese
aufnahmen hier erreicht und wir erhalten
das ganze immer kurz an und gucken uns
das entscheiden hier oben an das hier
ist die russische flagge wie erkennen
sie die trikolore das ist das einzige
was hier noch übrig ist wir sehen das
ganze das sind trümmer ein riesiges
trümmerfeld und nichts anderes das war
das hauptquartier der russischen armee
in residence quass in gestern von der
ukraine völlig vernichtet wurde das war
ein fünfstöckiges haus und ja man muss
sich schon fragen wie naiv waren die
russen denn das war das hauptquartier
des ukrainischen geheimdienstes fsb
vorjahr als es noch unter ukrainischer
kontrolle war offenbar haben die russen
gedacht super da war schon mal irgendwas
militärisch sondern da gehen wir jetzt
auch rein haben sich ja direkt rein
gesetzt und wir sehen jetzt hier
dutzende soldaten stehen ja ja etwas
verdattert und wahrscheinlich auch ja
natürlich auch traurig auf diesen
trümmern wenn wir sehen alles was da
drin war angeblich 100 russische
soldaten und offiziere ist nun nicht
mehr da und ist nun tot wo was ist hier
passiert wir haben die informationen
dass es sich hier um einen weiteren
kaymers angriff gehandelt hat das heißt
einen ukrainischen angriff mit diesem
amerikanischen raketensystem das ja man
muss sagen wirklich der game changer das
entscheidende was sie bekommen haben
bisher aus dem westen die heimat wir
sehen jetzt hier wie sie raketen
abfeuert die aufnahmen sind ungefähr
drei oder vier tage alt wir sehen wie
nacheinander die raketen herauskommt 84
kilometer weit fliegen sie auf drei
meter genau treffen sie ihre ziele und
bis zu sechs raketen in einer minute
können hier abgeschossen werden das also
dass heime system was ja schon der
horror ist für die russischen soldaten
nicht nur für die soldaten an der front
die haben sowieso jeden tag und nicht
die soldaten zu tun aber auch für die
generäle und für die offiziere weit
hinter der front die sich 20 30 50
kilometer hinter der front vielleicht
verstecken und versuchen von dort aus
den angriff zu planen auch das neue
aufnahmen aus nova kafka dieser angriff
hat bereits am 10 august stattgefunden
auch hier wieder ein heim us angriff und
wir sehen hier die völlige zerstörung
die russischen kamaz lkw die hier stehen
und auch außen rum die die basis die
russische militärbasis die einfach in
schutt und asche gelegt wurde auch dass
eine der besetzten städte in der ukraine
wir wissen von den usa dass die ukraine
diese high massen nur auf ukrainischem
boden einsetzen dürfen das zählt
übrigens auch dazu die krim das haben
die amerikaner ganz klar gesagt auch die
krimis ukrainischer boden auch dort darf
die heimat eingesetzt werden nicht aber
in wirklichen echten russland neben
diesen land das also aufnahmen jetzt
hier von vor etwa vor etwa fünf tagen
die auch ein heim us-angriff seinem zum
schluss wollen wir noch eine ein
kurioses video ansehen ein neues video
was uns auch erreicht hat aus dem osten
der ukraine hier sehen wir einen
russischen schützenpanzer vom typ bmp 1
und er ist voller soldaten das also
wirklich mit soldaten voll geladen und
wir schauen uns ganz kurz diese seltsame
szene an er fährt hier geradeaus auf der
straße und fährt hier ins ja ins grün
hinein und wir sehen links und rechts
sind ebenfalls bmp das sind die gleichen
schützen waren sagt die wurden dort
zerstört die wurden durch minen zerstört
dieser soldat der fahrer scheint zu
denken wenn ich da ganz gerade durch
ware durch meine zerstörten kollegen da
wird mir schon nichts passieren und wir
sehen genau das gegenteil ist der fall
er fährt ja auf eine weitere mine die da
liegt und auch dieser schützenpanzer
wird jetzt gut getroffen wir sehen die
soldaten alle richtungen ab springen
natürlich gibt es da auch verletzte das
ist gar keine frage
und trotzdem ein extrem kurioses video
wir haben schon öfter gesehen dass
russische soldaten sich durch
minenfelder versuchen durch schnelles
bewegen zu manövrieren natürlich weiß
jeder erfahrung und einem minenfeld muss
man sich fernhalten besonders wenn
eigens noch einmal kurz besonders wenn
er schon zwei weitere schützenpanzer im
minenfeld legen da noch durchzufahren
das ist wirklich eine ganz eigenartige
entscheidung die hier gefällt wurde von
diesen soldat die vielleicht auch leben
gekostet haben könnte
[Musik]